so here's a job opportunity that might
entice you New York City is searching
for an assassin someone with the means
and the Moxie to rat out the city's most
Elusive and hair-raising rodents the
city that never sleeps and now we know
why is offering an annual salary of up
to 170 000 US Dollars hoping to attract
a bold new leader for their long-running
battle
seeking candidates with good
communication skills and a bloodthirsty
attitude New York is on the hunt for a
rat Czar to fight the city's booming
rodent population
the rats don't run the city we do
the ad for a director of rodent
mitigation lists a swashbuckling
attitude and a general Aura of badassery
as criteria for the role previous
multi-million dollar efforts to improve
trash collection and cull rodents have
been thwarted by the city's cunning
furry residents everyone that knows me
they know one thing I hate rats you know
when we started killing them in Borough
Hall you know some of the same folks are
criticizing us now called me a murderer
because I was killing rats well you know
what we're going to kill rats rats have
no place in this city and we're going to
use every method that's needed to do so
so they're not harming families in our
quality of life
rat sightings in subways on streets and
even in homes have soared over 70
percent in the past two years the rodent
boom has been partly blamed on more
sidewalk dining in response to the
pandemic
mayor Adams said anyone with the drive
and Killer Instinct needed to fight the
city's rat problem should apply for
their dream job